hello everyone so I'm Miranda from the
Yahoo research in Haifa office I am a
senior research engineer and today I
will talk about automated extractions
for machine generated mail actually this
talk is based on the paper that was
recently accepted to the web conference
and I presented it last week in Lyon so
a and it is a follow-up to the previous
use case I described of classification
and I will it's a joint work with the
researchers from Yale and also where
production mail product team and I will
start with short intro okay so in your
research we do big data analytics so
what does the big data sources in the
world we have obvious images and videos
but also mail it say in your mail you
have around to a hundred twenty five
million monthly active users and it's a
large scale but why we focus on machine
generated mail in our projects mainly
because it's more than 95 percent of
your inbox a let's define what I mean
when I say a machine generated message
it's a message that was generated by
script by a machine and not by him
returned by human being for example
order confirmation travel itinerary
coupons marketing and so on what is so
special about this traffic first of all
it's highly structured its scripted a
note a person who typing a message and
it repeats it's large scale no one will
write the script to generate ten
messages it will be repeated many many
time for different users the same script
a script and yet it is very important
and personal data it's used in a lot of
features that helps user also for
marketing and the nature of this traffic
the fact that it's repeated large-scale
and very structured helps us apply
learning techniques and extractions so
now I will give you some motivation why
it's important to do extraction and
mainly automated many of the latest a
Yelp features in your male based are on
extractions for example here you have
the feature of clipping coupons coupon
extracted and you can save for later
coupons that you are interested in and
receive notifications when a coupon
expired or a travel a alert also you
have the latest shopping experience save
it's a deal with Ernie that enables you
to save money we extract the purchase
and the price and for each product we're
using Ernie we are able to to find the
if there is the same product for lower
price the user can really receive the
money back so all those features are
based on extractions from machine
generated messages and the high amount
of domains and use cases and structures
force us to do it automatically of
course and not manually so what is
information extraction let's go by an
example of a real my team a member his
flight confirmation so we want to
extract data pieces pieces of
information from his message and for
each text for each data we want to
associate it with a label contextual
label for example here the flight number
is you a nine five four we have also the
departure place on Francisco we have the
key of E string arrival a airport and so
so this is a task we want to solve to
extract the data pieces and annotate
them and the background also the same I
use the same a cluster type I used in
previous lecture is actually called X
cluster we use it here because this is
the input for our method
and this was suggested by my teammate
two years ago and let's follow an
example how we do the clustering given
this simple email a HTML message we want
to get there this signature to represent
the cluster this message belongs to how
we do it we said that we will look on
the structure not the content don't have
values it is himself so in order to know
what is the structure of HTML we look on
that Dom tree their HTML tags after we
are building this tree we will do
inorder traversal and a generate list of
X's actually XPath is a concatenation of
HTML tags and it's also important to do
it in the same order because the order
of the x possess is also important it
will affect the signature we receive we
are looking only on textual lives and
applying this mail hash signature the
that is a linear and very efficient
obviously it must be because we need
something that is scalable for the big
data we work with we receive this
signature so after we air I remind you
what is X cluster for those who heard
the previous lecture let's see how the
mail extraction process goes so our
process is consists of two parts of line
and all nine the offline part is the
cubes work actually at the online
offline part we generate the extraction
rule that later we will apply on a new
message that associated with the same X
cluster and then we will be able to know
what are the extraction extraction
values online how the probe line process
goes we need to collect the sample of
messages for each X cluster and for this
X cluster is actually the input is X
cluster table I will explain what is
they say data structure we use this is
the input and we have two phases to
create the rules we create a basic rule
and then refine it with contextual
annotations a okay so given we receive
this sample of messages from a specific
X cluster it array a a domain and this
is the extraction table in this table
each row represents a message in a
sample and each column belongs to X Y
all the messages in this sample aligned
why all of them have has exactly the
same columns because they belong to the
same X cluster it is a definition of the
X cluster so important part below so we
start with sampling and creating this
extraction table but with before we go
to the roots generation we also a
differentiate between constant and
variable exits in this example the third
x Pass is considered constant it has
exactly the same values for all the
samples like a header title for example
it's not interesting to extract it the
same for all the users it's not
something personal and the first and the
second exercise are variables they
contain information this is different
from one sample to another that is why
we will want to generate extraction
rules for X plus 1 and extraction rule 4
X plus 2 and so let's see what are the
steps to create rule as I said before
two steps basic rule and refine drew
let's look again by an example we have
this value for our experts departing at
9 a.m. first we are cleansing the
constant part in this value we are
removing the departing add because the
value we want to extract is 9 a.m. and
we also associate it with light
annotation time also this is the first
step this is a basic rule in there find
rule we will replace replace the time
annotation by contextual on the
station for this example it will be
departing time because we are talking
about a flight so so what annotations we
use oh it's not look very nice so we
have two types of annotation annotators
dictionary and format patterns but the
most important part are not a hitter's
if you can see that we need only some a
defined percentage of the samples to be
inside this dictionary or to match the
pattern for example in this table you
can see that the second string after
hello is a name but for my dictionary
for each annotation I created separate
dictionary for example for names I have
a list of names but I'm not able to
create a dictionary of all the names in
the world it's not feasible it will also
take very long time to check if it's
inside the dictionary or not so I will
take the most popular names and I need
only lets say 70% of the samples to have
the second word in the dictionary here
Jeff Ron Marisa
Francois Leon are in the dictionary so
the fact that he returned and Nick are
not part of the dictionary we're still
able to an as a annotate is the second
string as name the same goes for safe
patterns so for the dictionaries we use
it for names airport codes places and
for the second type of annotator it was
like URLs emails if you have a red X to
represent this structure play currency
numbers times dates and so on so after
we understand what are the lighter
notations it can be used in the
different use cases for travel for a
purchase it doesn't matter where this
date appears we will see how the rule
will look like so given that those are
the five out of 50 values for specific
experts in one of the x clusters in
United domain
this is the basic rule I want to
generate the extraction rule represented
by reg X the constant part of the red X
the check-in is open for actually is the
part we want to clean we want to remove
and each wild card represents the data
we want to extract when each wild card
associated with light annotation in this
example we are removing the check-in is
open for ethics from all the values we
see there then we take the string and
label it as flight number then we have
comma departing from and next value will
it will extract is associated with light
annotation place and so this is our
basic rule now we go to the second phase
of rule refinement now we want to give a
context we will look not for specific
column in our table not specific experts
will look on all the message in order to
understand the context and obviously
it's it's important what use case we are
working with because a context a
annotation we will replace are different
in different use cases for example here
we will replace four flights day to day
define date arrive date booking if we
are talking about purchase we will
replace the date by date purchase date
or if it's delivery when it it will
deliver and our approach to do so how we
know to what tell a context label to
replace is by classification as I said
before we're looking on all the X
cluster on full message and now we do
consider the constant expresses that we
ignore before because they contain a lot
of indicating words that can help us
through the classifications so let's
talk more about the classification part
we a train a model for each light a
notation
- they say when the positively when the
labels are the contextual annotations
that we want to replace - or for example
for date we saw that we will have three
labels optional labels like dates it can
be replaced to date a booking day
departing date right we will have
features for each light on notation
inside the XPath as the different
features we used are for example
relative exposition why it's important
because the booking date usually appear
on the top of the message and we want
our classifier to be able to learn it
also annotations before and after if
currently a never saw date before
current date cannot be they depart
because a sorry date arrived because you
need to see the day depart before the
date arrived so it's one of the features
what annotations you saw before what
annotations you saw after the current
light annotation is a constant values
HTML headers they all contain indicating
words like departs arriving and so on so
we trained our classifier and for each
light annotation we're able to place
here have some examples of how it will
look inside the message so here the
constant values can appear inside a
table as a header or just textual so we
are looking on the XPath before and this
XPath is a constant but we are taking it
into consideration in the refinement
step ok so now we know how to generate
the extraction rule and we receive a new
message and the expose value is as
follows and the extraction rule is like
they were built before but now we are
placed by contextual annotations and the
output the extractions we will receive
for this new value that we got are like
New York isn't associated with play
depart a beast
a b c n with airport arrival all those
values are extracted from this expose
using the extraction rule with just
generate any questions before we go to
the evaluation yes actually it's not
dependent on a language may be only the
lighter notations but we can create a
dictionary a actually we delete by
creating multiple rules for each expert
so if in a sample you will have 70%
english and 30% in french you can have
hello name and buns your name and then
we will try giving them as a new value
we will try to match if you receive the
message in English it will match the
second rule that start with Bonjour if
it's the English it will match hello so
it should handle a multi-language but it
depends on the sample you received if
it's very rare and you were we usually
sample for a week or two it depends so
if you never saw it so you will not be
able to generate the rule so a storm
statistics about the travel domain just
for you to understand how the x clusters
behave here we sorted the domains by the
number of x clusters it's a blue curve
and obviously it's exponentially
descending and the red curve actually
represents the traffic ratio when I talk
about traffic I mean what is the amount
what is the percentage of percentage of
travel messages that these domain
contained out of all the messages that
were a classifier dice trouble actually
we classify the clusters and if the
message belong to clusters that was
classified as travel it considered to be
travel message so you can see there is
no correlation you can have up to 60 a
cake clusters x clusters but your
traffic will not be the top
the highest percentage of messages here
we just shows the top flight domains
versus the X fasters number and you can
see that this method should be able to
handle domains that has a lot of faith
structures that tend to change
frequently and you have messages with a
little low amount of X clusters maybe
they're really big and then you have to
maintain less routes but here we suggest
automatic message so you you are seated
manually it will be really hard to
maintain it because it's not feasible we
will talk a little bit more about this
fact because as I said I need minimal
amount of sample in order to generate
true so I filter a X clusters that don't
have enough samples and I don't want to
lose a lot of coverage I will go to that
at the end of my evaluation so let's
let's just show what are the evaluation
results again yeah okay given it we work
with precision Rico and we looked based
on a manually label set of 850 X
clusters that covered six trouble
domains obviously the labeling was done
under full privacy privacy preservation
according to Yahoo privacy policy and we
see that the first step the basic rule
is very rich very high precision
recovery results with a most of them are
about 90% we we see that in Rico we
could improve and mainly given the
examples we saw it's by increasing the
dictionary it's easily by adding more
values to the dictionary we will
increase our Rico and they find
extractions a second step now I want to
know what is my classifier precision
even my lighter notation is correct do a
replace to the correct contextual
annotation and here again the result we
reached really high results all the
precision values are about 90%
we saw that also the recall is high I
saw that they'd booking we were a little
bit lower checking the label set we saw
that it's a peer really small amount of
times most of the X cluster didn't have
booking day and maybe in probably taking
the larger label set will improve these
results at last we looked on end-to-end
evaluation we took we compared with the
manual extraction given the current
extraction we having yow we looked on we
evaluated 10 million messages that
associated with 36,000 X clusters a it's
important to know that in tests we had a
100 domains and only 40 intersect with
the domains we had in our labeling set
so we obviously evaluated the new
domains that we didn't test at our
classifier class first on and again we
we saw that it healed really high result
a more than 90 percent in precision and
Rico and extraction extraction use case
focused on precision this is more
important for us because they are using
facing features and the precision here
is a high enough in order to be able to
show the users the extraction values and
blast is a promise to speak about the
sample size this parameter we call it
gamma and it's a trade-off if we take
really large x clusters really large
samples obviously our quality will be
higher and here we see it we need only
about 20 we used 50 samples to reach a
high enough that we don't adding more
samples didn't improve and if we look
only on large x clusters we will lose
with filter small x clusters but even
though taking largest of 20 samples
about 90% of the x clusters we took
still we see the coverage the amount of
messages amount of domains remains up to
85% and we are caring about the coverage
how many messages we extract from and
not the x clusters so it's a good enough
for us and I think the conclusions so we
showed the fully automated extraction
message method for machine generated
messages and we relied on the X cluster
our basic goal in dealing with machine
generated messages is usually to grouped
together messages it work generated by
the same script and then to learn and
apply different techniques we conducted
large-scale experiments and showed good
results on the classifier and also for
the online for the large-scale
experiments and the system product in
eyes in Yahoo Mail beckoned so and was
accepted to dub the dub conference is
here thank you
yeah you can you talk a little bit about
the machine learning models that you use
we tested several I think a we finally
we selected a random forest to be used
but it's a known techniques it's like a
vector of features that I showed before
and the random forest is the algorithm
we selected for a reclassification thank
you
[Applause]